tu me prendre la tension ascenseur à ce
que j'avais dit ascenseur moi tout un
choc aux moins bonne c'est que vous avez
déjà dit en premier à son sens moral on
va faire un père face quelqu'un gvt et
des ascenseurs au début non croyez que
ces déçus qui disait ascenseur qui
avaient la chance non non ça se passera
ce que je voulais dire en premier
ascenseur vous avez dit quoi en premier
chez vous mais attention pierre feuille
ciseaux il n'ya pas depuis celui qui
fait d'eux le puits est refait ici c'est
celui qui gagne pourra choisir où
l'ascenseur d'accord ok des escaliers
ascenseurs à sochi oui j'ai vomi aucun
j'ai vomi chimie je vous mets ascenseur
[Applaudissements]